okay
then okay yeah thank
you hello hello everyone here at the
Museum of Natural History uh we're glad
that you're joining us uh for today's
discussion on uh erosion of democracy
question mark academic freedom and
right-wing politics in Europe and also
um hello to everyone joining in uh via
the live stream and just uh for you um
since this is an open space we'll have
people uh close by to our discussion so
if you hear noises uh that's where they
are coming from but it shouldn't really
uh disturb you following our
conversation so welcome to you uh and
Welcome to our two panelists whom I will
introduce briefly uh in the next seconds
uh Christa Kovach Dr Christa Kovach and
Professor Tark
abar just to give you an idea what uh
you can expect uh during the next hour
um I'll briefly introduce the topic um
I'll introduce our two panelists who
will give uh short initial statements uh
regarding today's topic then we'll have
um about 20 minutes discussion here on
the panel after which you will have the
chance to ask your questions during
another 20 minutes and then we'll have a
quick wrap up final statements maybe um
and uh then you'll be on your way maybe
to further events during the Berlin
science week my name is Matias K uh I'll
be your host uh for the next hour I
represent
Theus Foundation based in Hamburg I'll
quickly
drop a word on that later I think the
mic is is it off can you listen can you
hear me okay yeah great thank you um
yeah so just to give you an idea um of
what we are going to talk about with our
two panelists um we've all been aware uh
of a certain Global Trend uh um towards
populism authoritarianism and right-wing
politics uh on a global scale maybe
rather faride politics we'll discuss
that uh during our um
discussion but this trend um is not one
that is um only relevant on a global
scale but also on a Europe European
scale um and this is interesting and the
focus of today's discussion because
Europe has long been hailed as and also
hailed itself as a stronghold um of
democracy but it's also within European
uh democracies that authoritarian
structures have taken hold that populist
strategies have taken hold think for
example of um the research of Shalini
randeria who speaks about soft
authoritarianism uh and thereby tries to
describe um the shifts in political
Landscapes and the fact that the
somewhat clear distinctions between
orthocraft authoritarian reges regimes
apply the rule of law to hollow out the
rule of law for example and she explicit
explicitly mentions Hungary and Poland
with regard to the global scale we also
talk about think of the academic freedom
index for example uh funded by the
Volkswagen Foundation that in its recent
survey uh of
2023 uh observes that in 22 of 179
countries worldwide there have been
significant decreases in academic
freedom meaning that almost half of the
world's population um lives in within
structures where academic freedom is
restricted in one form or another and
this also applies to European
countries one major aspect that we'll
talk about is the interrelation of um
democracy and academic freedom a major
Point uh of today's um discussion and
hinting at the title erosion of
democracy I think the the term erosion
is also very well chosen here because as
you know in geology it refers to a
gradual process of wearing something off
of tearing something down and I think
specifically with regard to European
Democracies this type of gradual process
of wearing off Democratic structures is
something that we as members of liberal
societies and as re researchers are
obviously very uh well aware of and have
to make ourselves aware of today's
discussion um within the Berlin science
week is organized by three chapters of
the Berlin University Alliance which as
you may know is comprised of four
institutions here in Berlin the humal
university the Free University the
Technical University and the Char
univers medicine Berlin and those three
chapters of the bua the Berlin
University Alliance are the cross
cutting theme
internationalization the the Berlin
Center for Global engagement and the
Oxford Berlin research
partnership as I said I represent the
side Foundation based in Hamburg uh
which is a foundation that has as its
mission statement um um the attempt to
Foster and strengthen liberal societies
by both uh maintaining own projects and
institutions such as a law school and an
art Forum the boerio art Forum in H
as well as funding projects by
individual researchers for example uh
and by institutions in areas of research
and scholarship which is the department
that I work in but also in education uh
and art for
example to there's one um specific uh
project that we maintain right now it's
uh an event series called protecting
academic freedom that takes place here
at Berlin State Library um called um
yeah called protecting academic freedom
of which the next event will be in
January regarding the interrelation of
Academia and democracy which is why we
were very thrilled to be invited to host
this event and I'm very glad to now be
able to introduce um our two speakers I
would like to head it off with um
introducing to
you once I find the correct sheet which
is this one thank you for your patience
uh by introducing to you um Professor
Tark abadi
tar is associate professor in European
union and comparative European politics
at the department of politics and
international relations and professorial
fellow at nuffield College of University
of Oxford his re research focuses on the
transformation of Party politics in
Western Europe and has contributed in
particular to a better understanding of
the rise of the radical right and of
green parties as well as the Electoral
crisis of of social
democracy he received the Henrik enderin
prize uh in 2021 for research excellence
in the social sciences which is jointly
awarded by the German Federal foreign
office the hatti school in Berlin um the
French Ministry for Europe and Foreign
Affairs and S Po in Paris since June
2023 he is an Einstein Berlin University
Alliance uh Oxford visiting fellow here
at Humber visitate in Berlin and in this
capacity he will set up a working group
here in Berlin to study voting
preferences in European
comparison Tark it's great to have you
here thank you for joining us um and to
head off with your initial statement
based on your research how would you
describe how far R politics have changed
Europe in the past
years so if we want to understand or
describe the success of the radical
right in the in the past 20 years we can
look at two different things the first
is something like institutional power so
how strong has the radical ride become
in our parliaments in governments and so
on and there we can distinguish
different phases and different states at
the moment in Europe there's one that is
just just sees the radical right as a
fringe party right the radical right
isn't represented in Parliament it's not
in government it is really a party on
the fringes that used to be the real
reality in most European States but this
has basically disappeared the the faride
is nearly nowhere still a fringe party
and in many countries they have reached
this very crucial Next Step that is
parliamentary representation so now in
Europe we basically see the radical
right the far right represented in
nearly in Parliament in nearly all
countries um still there we can
distinguish their their influence a
little bit they might be represented and
in some countries like in Germany
there's there's still something around
them what we call a COR so other parties
have decided and Germany is very often
called the brma um have decided more or
less um not to collaborate with this
party and this still limits their
institutional power and then there are
other examples where these parties have
become really established actors in
European parliaments they have supported
government coalitions they have become
parts of government coalitions the
Netherlands Denmark are examples of this
um and then of course there's the next
step where um they even lead governments
and this has also become the reality in
some European countries of course um in
Hungary in Poland still but probably not
not for a long time anymore um Italy of
course is another example and what we
can see in in some of these countries
not only the ones where they have become
these leading parties in governments is
that that that they have taken over as
the main party of the right and this is
really a crucial watershed moment so
it's something that you can also see in
France at the moment for example where
the radical right party has really
become the main party on the right and
the mainstream right party has
disappeared to a certain degree and this
is this is a crucial Watershed for their
for their institutional power there's a
second thing that we shouldn't forget
when we discuss the influence of the
radical ride and that is the ideological
and programmatic impact so the impact of
the radical RI is not just through
institutions and the parties themselves
but the biggest issue with the radical
right is of course radical right
ideology and so we have to ask ourselves
how have these parties met manage to
affect what other parties do where
policies go how we we lead our discourse
and there as well we can see um a strong
impact of the radical Riot we can
measure this when the radical Riot
becomes U becomes more successful other
parties shift their positions on
immigration for example if you look at
rhetoric and I like to do this with my
students sometimes you take a radical
rights state you don't give them the
name of the party or the politician you
take a radical right statement from the
early 2000s that say for pimp for and
then um you take a contemporary
mainstream right politician statement
let's say in Shan for example and you
will they will very often not be able to
distinguish these statements anymore um
because there what what used to be
radical right positions on many issues
have become positions of um the
mainstream that or have become positions
that mainstream parties government
parties governments have have taken up
um so we always have to keep these two
things in mind I think when we want to
assess where the rical ride currently is
thank you very much uh for this um you
will have as I mentioned you will have
the opportunity to ask questions and we
will take the aspect that you just
mentioned and you will mention as well
in your statements into our discussion
and please feel free to keep in mind
your questions uh regarding those for
later on um thank you Tark for your
statement um opening up the discussion I
would like to uh transition to
introducing to you uh Dr Christa Kovach
as our second panelist she is a senior
research fellow at the VIS vens shft
Centum uh here in Berlin uh at the
cluster of Excellence contestations of
the liberal script or short scripts and
there she works within the project
science friction patterns causes and
effects of academic freedom
contestations she is also an associate
professor at El University in Budapest
at the UNESCO chair for human
rights she worked for more than 10 years
as an adviser at the Hungarian
constitutional court and as a liaison
officer at the Venice Commission of the
Council of Europe her research is mainly
focused uh on international human rights
on comparative politics constitutional
law and on academic
freedom Christa uh following this brief
introduction uh to you and your work
what effect uh had the ri uh the rise of
far R Politics on the state of academic
freedom in Europe particularly
thank you um thank you so much I'm
really grateful for the opportunity to
speak about my research uh today um and
today it is about academic
freedom um let me say that for a long
time uh academic freedom had been taken
for granted in Europe right uh but
recently uh there have been dramatic
declines in the in the so-called
academic freedom index what uh Matias
cooch has already mentioned this is by
the way an index that was prepared by uh
two colleagues of mine Katherine
kinzelbach and Yanik panagal they also
work in this um in this research team
science fiction what is this index is
about it measures the the state of
academic freedom in in each country um
and it it it does so uh based on the
evaluation of more than 2,000 uh
Scholars worldwide
and you probably notice that I use the
term uh academic freedom and not for
instance freedom of science right um and
this is because um these two terms are
not the same um if we talk about uh the
freedom of science it is a it is an
abstract term it is an umbrella term it
um encompasses the the right to science
which is a right uh which is a human
right every human being has the right to
to engage in scientific activity uh to
discover what is truth so if for
instance if we make experiments at home
uh we are engaged in scientific activity
but there is another uh side which is
academic
freedom and this academic freedom is a
is a professional Freedom so it's the
professional freedom of the
researchers like us who chose uh to do
research as a profession right uh and
this is a little this is measurable in a
way uh so today I'm SP I'm speaking
about this term so academic freedom and
as I have mentioned already uh there
have been dramatic declines recently in
the field of academic freedom in many uh
European countries most notably Hungary
Poland but also in in Russia and
Turkey um and this
these declines clear clearly relate to
uh to far right politics or radical
right Politics as as T put it uh and
autocratization
uh what what we witness in in these
countries uh is two
things one is um at the structural level
um um public universities are have been
shut down in in Russia and Turkey
private university uh has been forced
out uh of
Hungary um public universities have been
put under So-Cal total of uh Board of
Trustees in the in those countries and
academic disciplines uh have been banned
I will speak about it uh later a little
bit more in
detail and we also see that there are
problems at the individual level so um
researchers who criti ize this uh face
uh
intimidation carrier um blocking or or
even dismissal so um so I think there is
a a clear link between the state of
academic freedom and uh the quality of
democracy in a in a given
country thank you Christa uh for um
giving us first insights into what you
are working working on and thank you
also for differentiating between
academic freedom and freedom of science
because I think this is um a good way to
transition uh into our uh discussion
here um on the panel because um we
wanted to discuss and talk later on also
with you uh about the interrelation uh
between academic freedom uh and
democracy and I think when you
differentiate those two the way you just
did you could say that the basic
Democratic freedom of scientific
activity is sort of the second term that
you described for example engaging in
scientific experiments at home uh which
also has to be allowed in a sense um but
the more professionally uh coined
academic freedom would be another part
of this so um yeah I'd invite to opening
up our um discussion to maybe elaborate
a little bit further on this
interrelation between democracy and um
academic
freedom so me me again absolutely really
feel free to jump in any time
I think it's a a relatively new
phenomenon
to to realize that um academic freedom
has a deep connection to uh to democracy
to Liberal Dem to Liberal constitutional
um democracy and it's new because um
what is needed is the recognition that
um intellectual inquiry is important
understanding
ourselves uh the nature around us and
and the social um word around us is is
important and there are other pre
conditions
too uh my colleague uh in the research
team Matias Kum rightly points out that
for instance the rise of the uh the
modern University as we know it is very
important the Hulan idea of um of uh
doing science at universities teaching
and doing research at the same time is
very important important and also a a
third thing which is the the
democratization of the University so it
it happened only in the 20th century
that universities opened uh themselves
to the to the population right so today
University is not just for the
privileged VI um but what the what's the
what's the the connection right between
academic freedom and and and democracy
uh I would say that um academic freedoms
support individual
autonomy in a sense that during our
lives we should make very very many uh
important
decisions uh decisions on health issues
financial matters or political matters
and in order to make a an informed
decision we need science so we are
we are in the need
of understanding and knowing uh the our
health uh our health issues and and also
the possibilities of the Medical Science
and we also need to understand the
political process right uh to in order
to v um to go V so this is this is one
thing so academic freedom supports U
individual um self-government but it
also so um support Collective
self-government in a way that uh the the
insights and
arguments generated by uh scientists
inform political
decision uh this is what we see during
the pandemic that medical experts uh
gave their opinion and uh and this these
opinions in for politics well not in
Hungary where uh where it was um
prohibited that medical experts gave
interviews uh to to the to the Press but
in in Germany we uh could really see
that uh Medical Science informed
political decisions so uh so academic
freedom serves both individual and
Collective self-government and and this
is and this is why I think academic
freedom matters not only to us
researchers but but to to everyone else
MH T would you like to add to that um
yeah I guess what I um yes and I very
much agree with with everything that's
been said I think it's important that we
take into consideration not only the
institutional embedding of Academia and
their freedoms but also the the
individual research and you you you you
emphasized this and that um that I think
very often when we think of uh the
question of academic freedom we think
okay does a government allow
free research or allows universities to
basically operate in um independent of
what the government wants but of course
there are there there are many
individuals that are constantly involved
in the process of doing research but
also communicating research so what we
have to think about if we think of
especially also the the radical right or
the far right Onslaught on on academic
freedom is that it doesn't only happen
when the reic provid is in power but of
course it happens very concerted in um
in spaces like on social media for
example right so that the that academic
freedom doesn't only mean I don't go to
prison if I say something that the
dictator doesn't like but it means to be
able to um communicate with the the
broader public without being threatened
for example and there the Netherlands is
a good example where there was a group
that very um specifically targeted women
scientists who were visible in uh in the
public some of them political scientists
doing research on the Ric right but also
virologist for example was kind of the
the the Christian Tron equivalent in in
the Netherlands when they were very
specifically targeted with for example
stickers on their door at home that says
we see you right and so there were these
these really um um extreme tactics of
intimidation and we shouldn't forget
this element when we when we talk about
academic freedom because that too um
very much affects who who can speak in
public who's heard and and and and who
can make a contribution to public
understanding of
science yeah I think that's very
important to highlight the personal side
of it as you both did because it also
shows that academic freedom is nothing
abstract but it's very specific it has
very specific a very specific
significance for our everyday lives um
um and therefore also needs to be
protected very specifically uh since you
mentioned the personal side to it um I'd
like to ask you uh what in your personal
views would be needed to Foster and
strengthen uh the conditions needed to
do um academically free work uh and in
which way um you have also observed
restrictions maybe also on your own
work
yeah I also
observed um when
I when I don't uh conduct research on
academic freedom uh then I uh re search
um the rule of law situation in in
Central Europe in in Hungary and Poland
and also I tried to ask the question
what the European Union can do in those
countries and um exactly because of this
um I am on the on the on The Blacklist
of of the government I mean uh I'm I'm
listed as the enemy of the Hungarian
people uh because of my research and the
Hungarian governing uh
I mean online Portales uh list me as the
enemy of the people and and as a
globalist academics who uh who hates
Hungary and things like that so it's uh
it's it's not an easy thing always to to
to do and conduct research uh in in such
an environment and it's not an
coincidence that I'm sitting here in
Berlin in the Berlin science week and
not in pest talking about things like
that academic freedom and uh the rule of
law uh so yes we feel it and um and
researchers uh like myself for instance
who who who um conducts research on on
rule of law and democracy and publicly
expresses um um their opinion we often
um the target of the smar campaigns um
and the government usually call us uh
SOS uh agents or mercenaries you know
George shuros the the philanthropist who
is originally from Hungary but lives in
the US so basically the government
denies us the the the moral integrity
and and agency so that's that's just the
personal background uh um yeah Tariq
maybe you can add add some to that
because it's also important yeah and
obviously speaking from a very
privileged position where right I don't
have these these institutional barriers
at all um but I think I wanted to to
emphasize again something where I'm I'm
quite privileged in in in this regard is
also the freedom to aspect of of of of
academic freedom so who can participate
at conferences in in research exchange
who has what resources to do their their
own research and I think this is
something where where as a discipline or
or generally as as as as Academia we
also need to critically reflect um what
we do and how we interact and for
example having the right passport is a
crucial um component of being able to
travel to conferences for example I know
I have so many colleagues for whom it's
really really difficult who are based in
the UK now and if they want to travel to
Europe they need a visa and these Visa
processes take a long time and so for
example the these mechanisms hinder the
free exchange that that that Science is
based on um and so in also in Academia
we see these struggles um that are for
example based on on Citi ship really um
reproduced very often um and of course
we also see economic concentration of uh
of wealth and resources as a problem of
uh um of Academia and obviously I'm
speaking from an institution that is
this is generally seen as quite well
funded um but there there are many
others where we see that this strong
concentration where we have some
universities and some entities that have
a lot a lot of money um compared to
other universities and research bodies
that don't have that money um again if
you we think from a perspective to the
the freedom of doing the freedom to do
science the right way um we should ask
also ask ourselves and and and and
critically reflect on the political
processes um that have not seen an
increase in spending on on on science
research and education in the last year
rather to the
contrary yeah I think that's also a very
important distinction you said the
freedom too because if you take sort of
a traditional um concept of Freedom it
would always be double-sided right it's
the freedom from oppression for example
and the freedom to for example have
access to funding for example uh and the
question of whether or not that is
distributed in an equal way
absolutely since we now talked about
academic freedom I would like to for
sort of the second part of our
discussion to uh transition in a way to
the rightwing or rather farri um
politics that um make up the second part
of the
um pair of freedom and democracy namely
democracy that we talked about and T um
I'd like to ask you um what are the
factors that have contributed to the
rise of far ride politics uh in the last
year yeah so what we usually do when we
when we try to make sense of this and of
course it's a it's a difficult thing to
study it's very multi-dimensional
there's not one reason for the rise of
the radical Riot um and certainly
there's not one across countries and
times and so on so we one one challenge
as a researcher is to somehow reduce
this complexity and have certain
Concepts that we can use to put some
order into into the chaos and um one
thing that we usually distinguish is
questions of demand and Supply so demand
is what people want from politics um and
so when we think about the rise of the
radical ride we can think of the issues
that people um that are important to
people when they vote for the radical
right when they support the radical
right right here and this is not going
to come to as a surprise to anyone of
course we know that immigration is the
number one issue immigration has been
the number one issue um that has fueled
the rise of the radical right um what we
also know is that it it has less to do
with actual numbers of immigration um it
has less to do with um what the
situation of immigration actually is and
it has much more to do with how a
feeling has been created or how people
Embrace a feeling where they perceive a
threat through immigration and there two
ways they can perceive their threat they
can perceive that threat economically um
that is I'm for example I'm competing
with migrants for work um and they can
see that threat culturally right so
immigrants are coming for example that
have a different religion and I see the
basic principles that I believe our
nation should embrace eroded through um
that immigration and these two things
really make a core um of the demand for
the radical right but it's important to
to to keep in mind that it's not only
immigration um and and and and and
another element that's really essential
in this um demand for the radical right
is um what we call authoritarianism here
authoritarianism less as this form of
government that is the opposite of
democracy but more as a as a personality
trade in the sense that you want
societies organized top down you want
Law and Order you want to be the things
to work a certain Right Way um for
everyone instead of being more free and
bottom up and that authoritarianism is
um is a core of the radical right and it
with that perspective it Embraces
different different topics immigration
is one um something that is increasingly
really becoming an issue of the radical
right is the field of um gender um
gender politics so where the radical
right really embrac this anti-gender
anti-lgbt um positions and again from a
very authoritarian Aran um we want to we
know what is normal and everything else
is deviant and this is a logic really
that that that fuels the the radical
right that's from the demand side from
the supply side then this is what do
political leads other political actors
do here the most important actor is the
radical rights itself so do they have a
functioning organization um do they have
politicians that are skilled politicians
or are they very much in in fighting um
do they have enough money um and all of
these things and there you can already
see the self reinforcing process when
the radical right becomes
institutionalized they they get more
resources they become more attractive
for opportunist politicians um and
because of this we see this this
reinforcement and if I can add a final
thing that I think is really important
and this is the normalization of the
radical right um
so 20 years ago in many countries there
was a norm around not supporting the
radical Riot and in some countries there
was a very strong norm and we have seen
step by step that Norms been eroded and
it's become increasingly the radical R
has become an increasingly legitimate
and normalized actor their positions
their rhetoric and so on and this has
been largely done through media actors
other political actors and the general
public um and again this then helps the
radical right to really become um the
strong actor that it is
now mhm thank you um Christa would you
like to add to that maybe with um focus
on Hungary for example since um TK
mentioned um the specific forms of
authoritarianism and the supply and
demand um
structure yeah yeah in Hungary radical
right authoritarian party is in
government so uh there we can see uh
that it has um I mean it has an e it has
an effect on academic freedom as well uh
so what we can see is what just uh Tark
mentioned that um the the government um
gives you what's the point of academic
freedom the limits of academic freedom
and the and the goals the science should
uh achieve so it's a very top- down
thing um when it comes to academic
freedom Hungary is the worst European
Union member today uh previously uh
according to the oecd numbers the uh
institutional autonomy was around uh 65%
in the early '90s uh but in in 2015 it's
just uh 29% I don't know how they
measured that but still it's a it's a
huge decline uh and we know why is that
I mean I listed a couple of things um
the forcing out of a private university
from the country I I probably don't
mention but I just realized that it it
is important to mention that uh the
government government uh dropped gender
studies and uh in introduced uh family
studies whatever it means uh and
something similar happened by the way in
Poland Poland Dred anthropology and
introduced uh the study of culture and
religion so they they try to navigate or
uh organize academic um academic uh
policies um and of course public
universities are uh are are put under uh
total Edge under Board of Trustees and
the members of these Board of Trustees
are uh appointed by uh the government or
sometimes even the Prime Minister
himself um Research Center are organized
into uh networks and the network is
reviewed by the ministry so the research
topics uh should be approved by the
politics uh and yeah I can I can
continue like this for a wrong time but
I give it back to you
I'm sure it's true yeah thank you very
much um before opening the floor to our
audience and uh their questions um I'd
like to ask you one final question uh to
the both of you and that would be what
um what could be done uh in a sense um
what could be potential strategies that
would help curb the spread of faride um
ideologies and in that sense also to
strengthen uh Dem Democratic principles
both in society and uh and in Academia
and really feel free to
okay
um yeah this is always the the one very
difficult question
so what is important I think is to
realize that there's no magic formula
that will make the radical right
disappear and I think in in the next
year or five years or even probably 20
years the rical r has become an
established actor in European
Democracies and this is something that
to a certain degree we have to live with
for now I think very often in the
attempt to make the rical ride disappear
again things actually have been done um
that strengthen the rical ride and I'll
talk about this in a second this doesn't
mean that we should be you know we
should give up and say Well they're just
there well whatever um it means that we
need to think of containment more than
of strategies of how um how they will be
gone again and then then this is I'm not
happy to say this but I think this is
this is the truth of where we are right
now because in many countries is we
really see this step-by-step development
where the radical right is becoming the
main actor of the right where the
radical right is leading governments and
so on and if you once you've reached
that point you you're starting to play a
completely different game then really
the game is about democracy itself it's
not about policies and directions within
democracies anymore but then it's really
about the survival of democracy and this
is a very different game to play what I
what I can say is a couple of things
that that we shouldn't do the the most
important thing is we shouldn't
accommodate the radical right so the
idea that we need the idea that many
politicians pursue to say we need to win
voters back from the radical right by
becoming a light version of the radical
right has not worked it hasn't worked
anywhere it's not going to work people
at the end of the day will vote for the
original um so what what in the the
short-term Solutions are very difficult
right there has a lot to do with uh with
with with ups and downs of s salian
Cycles what what we talk talk about but
they're again not talking about um
immigration every time kind of like 95%
of the day if I listen to the radio in
the morning at the moment you seem this
it seems like except for one other major
issue at the moment seems this is
everyone every Everything everyone's
talking about um and even when you're
talking about immigration there are very
different angles to talk about
immigration do you focus on deportation
or do you f focus on the humanitarian
aspect of it do you actually talk to
people people who have fled their
countries because of war and and hunger
and and so many things all do talks to
the afd politician who uses them for
their own political goals so these are
these are some shortterm things where we
can try to not feed the radical ride
attention cycle and then in the long
term um we need to ask ourselves how the
fundamental
insecurities that the big
Transformations that we're witnessing
have created with people that have led
some people to that have mobilized this
connection of anti-immigrant
authoritarian um attitudes with a
certain type of of insecurity um and how
we can break these up in and by create
politically creating um a um higher
levels of economic security for example
um by not giving up the the progressive
positions that we think we want to live
in um in diverse societies and we want
to have policies that that treat people
equally and if I can give one example of
of of my own research where um we can
see a positive change in attitude so
what we've studied is um the impact of
marriage equality legislation on
attitudes and while generally we can see
in Europe that attitudes have become
much more positive um toward gay
lesbians bisexuals um we what we can
show is where these laws have been
passed where where samesex marriage has
been passed these attitudes become much
more positive much more quickly so in by
creating progressively inclusive
institutions we also make people more um
inclusive and more accepting of
diversity and so sometimes it's
important to change laws and change
policies also against majorities to then
affect how people think about the
world thank you tar Christa would you
like to uh add to that well yeah maybe a
couple of thing how can we strengthen
academic freedom
uh I think the European Union can could
do a lot in this sense um as we all know
um in every University there is a
self-governing body usually we call it a
senate and this self-governing body is
responsible for making decisions or
educational educational matters and
matters of research
matters uh and if uh if you think about
U an authoritarian uh country in this
country uh and the university is
captured which means that the that the
decisions on Education and Research is
not uh made by this self-governing body
but it is a decision made by the
government or the ministry so it's a
topd decision so I think here the EU
could do more uh the EU could uh demand
um to restore the Senate's right or the
uh self-governing body's right to to
decide on educational and and research
matters and also uh it would also help
if if if the European Union
uh did not Finance uh institutions that
are not uh that that do not operate uh
under academic uh science or scientific
standards um and also I think
universities from uh from other
countries like Germany uh can help by
organizing uh networks uh with the
remaining in uh inter with the remaining
independent institution in in those
countries but they should be aware of
that not every institution in those
countries in for instance in Hungary uh
operate under these academic standards
so should be careful when they do
this thank you so much uh to the two of
you you've given us a lot to think about
um uh and I would now now like to open
um our discussion towards um all of you
uh we have colleagues here with handheld
microphones uh and please feel free to
uh ask a question we have the first one
I think already up here good now
yeah I thank you for that that was super
interesting I'm always I'm from South
America but I'm always interested to see
you know how rightwing is developing all
over the world and yeah it's a bit scary
but also interesting to to learn more
about it um and my question is like how
why is it that you know rightwing the
more extremities uh provoke such an
emotional reaction out of people that
there's not really um a valid
alternative in the left let's say so
there's not been a rise in a
more like well there is populist left
but it hasn't been as effective let's
say as the right wing or right-wing in
every other party so I don't really
understand what is the emotional like
impact that this has on people that it's
so effective you
know did you direct your question to one
of our parents in particular yeah open
okay so really feel free to take it off
if you have a good answer CU not I wish
all right I'm working on it yes great um
I I'll try to work on it while I'm
speaking no so I think this is this it's
an acent point right so why why is the
radical right so good in
translating feelings of status loss and
insec economic insecurity into support
for them and why isn't the left good at
this and this is a question we really
try to to pin down and we haven't find
the the a great answer for it yet um
generally right why is economic
inequality not more of an issue of um of
the politics of the day um it's not that
there hasn't been right there are
movements who are obviously trying it
right there is a there is a leftwing
populism in um in Europe that functions
differently from the um from the radical
right and this might be one reason I
think it's a good thing that it
functions differently in the sense that
um the the populace left in Europe or
the radical left in Europe is much less
anti- system um than the than the
radical right and it's much less
populist in its
anti-pluralist uh components than than
the radical right which makes the the
the European radical left really not an
equivalent to the radical right and in
terms of its threat to democracy and
threat to Liberal democracy and so
on which is a good thing um but which
might be connected to why they are less
successful in this regard and creating
this emotional response when people
support the radical
right out of a a sentiment of status
loss they don't do so because they think
the radical right has the right policy
Solutions but they want to change the
rules of the game they their feeling is
the world is moving away from a world
where my position is valuable um and
this sounds like I'm pitying them too
much which which you shouldn't because
in the end they decides was qu right um
but that insecurity is translated really
into a demand that means changing the
rules of the game and this is not
something necessarily that the um the
left is providing in um uh in Europe and
the right more radical left is also more
integrated still into institution into
organizations and and political parties
where also more moderate forces come
together and and and formulate a vision
um that that is different from from from
uh that of the of the radical right
where really the radical right is
increasingly cannibalizing other parts
of the um of the center right yes I'll
leave it with
that so it's a really difficult question
um I think authoritarians uh usually
emphasize homogeneity you do know the
sameness uh already kmid did that um and
I if I were a a politician I think I
would I would stress that dis Agreements
are natural so it's natural that we
think uh differently about how to lead a
good life uh and we shouldn't avoid
rational debate usually autocrats uh
would love to avoid rational debate
Donald Trump avoid uh Victor Orban
avoids rational debate they are not good
at rational debate so I I think what we
should do is to uh to facilitate these
type of discussions and going back to my
uh my point the universities can be a
good places for that to facilitate uh
this typ of open and in an inclusive
dialogue uh for every type of uh
disagreement and
points thank you I see another question
there yes I I want to start piggybacking
a little bit on this I I'm from the US
but fortunately left 15 years ago I'm
alarmed at what goes on there now but I
I agree what I have been seeing is that
there's people are almost like change
voting change for change sake that's not
always the good path to take but my
question is and I I have this need to
try to figure out how do we like you
were saying I think it's important we're
at a Crossroads that we need to start
having different conversations I think
we need to drop o this what's
politically correct to say or not to say
because who defines that anyway I I
think we need to say some things but
always with in a respectful way we want
to be heard but how do we start getting
people to move away from the lies and
the conspiracy theories and the media
kind of things and start really having
real discussions and encouraging that
and setting up platforms that's that's I
just recently moved to Berlin because I
think this is a place to start that and
I moved here to participate in that
exclusively so any ideas on you know how
do you combat this other world that's
out there and get back into having those
real discussions that are
necessary thank you Christa would you
like did you direct your question to one
of our panelists in particular no really
yes absolutely Christa would you like to
um yeah I have only a a small Point um I
absolutely agree that Berlin is a good
uh place to start a rational dialogue uh
I really Envy of the uh of those who are
making politics in in Germany because
here the political debates are about
real issues uh and and uh and not about
emotions but about um reasons and
rational um ideas um I'm not so sure
about the your other point on political
correctness I know what you mean and I
think it it probably went so far but I
think it is important to to to respect
the other person's human dignity and
this is what I mean when when I when I
think about political correctness this
is what I have in mind to to protect and
to respect the other person's dignity uh
you know
yeah but but my question is always I
mean if we want to be heard there's a
way that we have to invite the other
person to listen and it can't be on
disrespecting them but I think you know
we start need to asking that when people
come up with these coin phrases or like
you know political correctness who to
finds that why do we why do we give so
much Authority away for whoever these
segments to find that where do we know
where that even comes from I mean I'd
like for somebody to to to totally tell
me what does it mean to be politically
correct Define all of it I think that
would be a really good topic for the
next panel discussion what does it mean
to be a politically correct uh debate
yeah sorry um so I I'll I'll Focus first
on the on the first point about the CH
people wanting change for change sake um
where it
is that is something that is happening
and and in Central and Eastern Europe um
some some colleagues have coin the term
of a new party sub electorate so
basically a share of the electorate that
will nearly always vote for a new party
um and and and there are mechanisms for
this has a lot to do with an anti- elite
sentiment but in these countries for
example a lot with corruption as well
but we're seeing this increasingly in
some Western European countries as well
for example NE the Netherlands are a
good example where even the radical Riot
has become more fragmented and
increasingly um right the the
established radical Riot seems to be
less attractive than some new version of
the retical right so there really seems
to be that mechanism um that that is
driving quite a bit of electoral
behavior um and and and and and the last
one on how we engage people people who
have gone down the rabbit hole
conspiracy theories or conspiracy
ideologies to a certain degree again I
think there there's a share of people we
will not reach um that that is the truth
I think we have to create better
mechanisms
of detecting when people radicalize what
the contexts are in when that happens um
when we talked about
radicalization in the last 20 years it
always nearly always meant political
Islam or Islamic uh terrorist
radicalization a little bit about the
radical right but really this there
there is a Nexus in in in many records
of society also of young people right um
I don't know what researcher really
understands gaming culture for example I
certainly don't do right so there are
many um communicative spaces that we
don't even have access to so it's become
so difficult to to understand and study
them and I think there we need to the
first step is just really to better
understand what's going on in these um
in these spaces um and then have I an
early warning system in place because at
a certain point when people have reached
a certain point it will be very
difficult to get them back from that
point and I think for for for a certain
share of of people which isn't a large
share of people um but there is one that
are so um deep down in the world of
conspiracies that it will be basically
impossible to reach them and so we need
to understand better how and when that
happens more early
on I saw two more questions in the
audience and uh with regard to the time
I think we would have to draw to a close
after those but we do have time for
those two please I think my question
went in a similar Direction because like
going down the road of becoming more
radical rightwing let's say like how
yeah it's about how um how to talk to
people how to get them back I mean you
said some people can't be reached
anymore but on the
transitioning there some people I I feel
like more and more people are not
reachable through rational debate right
but while they still are a little bit
like what are the right questions to ask
or the right approach because just
saying like what you're saying right now
is racist doesn't really help usually
and do you have best practice for that
cont
this is a
question what what's I think one what's
important to realize if if you're
talking about the radical right right
now we're not and this this is the part
of the the problem is we're not talking
mainly about those super radicalized
ideologues with with conspiracy theories
in Italy more than 40% of the electorate
voted for the radical right in Poland
more than 40% still voted for for for
the radical right um so we're talking
about a much broader phenomenon and and
and there um what we need to ask is how
such a large share of people has come to
the conclusion that this is serving
their interests um and so I don't even
know necessarily always if this is an if
if dialogue with them is the only way of
of getting there we just need to ask
ourselves
how um political actors also have shaped
this idea of a very strong the ends
justify the means idea so many people
don't particularly like Donald Trump but
they are still convinced that he will
serve them in the right way that will
serve their goals and that he is better
than the alternative and that that what
whatever the whatever means he uses or
whatever means authoritarians generally
use justifi these means are Justified
even if they undermine democracy because
political actors have been successful in
creating an image of if if it's not that
then it's the it's Socialism or whatever
it is that that threat is or it is it is
right the is great replacement things
like that and I think there there is one
of the big challenges
thank you T Kaa would you like to add to
that question or should we okay then
we'll transition to our final question
please fin question for you thank you U
just want to thank everyone as well it's
been a very fascinating discussions
thank you for that um so overall there's
a bit of a old cliche that um the
younger sort of generations start off a
lot more progressively leaning and sort
of overall a lot more leftwing in their
politics and that people increasingly
move further to the right as they age um
but now we're seeing a lot more from dat
actually younger demographics are
increasingly voting for more
authoritarian parties and overall less
Democratic Solutions probably in
reaction to uh increasing sort of
frequencies of major crises that people
are facing so my question is what sort
of strategies can we sort of employ in
order to Showcase Democratic solutions
to combat this Rising desire for more
authoritarian
politics that I can actually
answer I think Democratic education
would be an important thing um and what
was missing in hungary's um two decades
of democracy is a plan how to teach the
new generation what democracy is and why
uh democracy is
important and I think that it is uh it
is it is that it is not something uh
self-evident you know that we should
work for it um every day to to to make
it happen
um and it's not just um a topic for a
university seminar but also uh something
that um pupils can uh talk about uh in
the school so
um and and yes if the children don't
learn the uh the very early importance
of democratic debate and the Democratic
process that they don't cherish a
democracy at least this is the the
lesson that I learned from the Hungarian
political
experience so the um with starting with
the diagnosis it is true that younger
cohorts it's not only age it's actually
younger cohorts are more Progressive in
terms of their attitudes and we see more
younger people voting for The Radical
rights than uh older people and it's
also true and this seems like a
contradiction in in the beginning but it
is necessarily um because the reason why
older people vote less for the radical
Riot is they have still much stronger
party attachments with traditional
parties um so they have they are still
the the people who identify with the
labor party with a Social Democratic and
mainstream right party um and so these
people just generally vote less for
newer parties so with younger people
what we have is that on average younger
people are more Progressive but younger
people are just much more willing to
vote for a party that is not the center
right or the center left and because of
this we see this what what what looks
like a discrepancy among the young as
well not everyone's Progressive right
this is an average and so we see these
averages moving but many young young
people are rightwing what we see and
what should wor us and I think this
disconnects this is that the radical
right is becoming more normal among
younger people so we see more young
people saying they would potentially
consider voting for a radical right
party um and there we really again see
this normalization of the rical ride and
it makes a lot of sense if you grow up
with everyone talking about let say
theal as it were just you know this it
is that candidate was in a presidential
runoff twice then obviously that that
it's much more difficult to have that
stigma um and and the norm against these
parties um and so there I think is like
looking into the future is really the
The Challenge and then this is political
education social education to um to make
sure that this normalization doesn't
doesn't even increase um among younger
cohs thank you so much um sad to say uh
we have run out of time for today's
discussion obviously the both of you tar
and Christa have given us a lot to think
about further um I'd like to thank you
again for sharing your insights with us
uh today I'd like to ask thank our
audience for their time and questions um
and um all there's left to say is um
take care and if you plan to join
further events um here at the Berlin
science week uh um enjoy them um it's a
huge program waiting for you for the
next couple of days and chrisan Tark you
take care as well and we'll see you at
the future event thank you so much thank
you for your
[Applause]
attention